Avengers endgame provided a defining
moment for Scarlett Johansson's Natasha
Romanoff aka Black Widow 1 which caused
the stir among many MCU fans in an
Entertainment Weekly interview directors
Joe and Anthony Russo felt the need to
clarify their thinking and including the
scene which one could hardly argue was
out of character for Romanoff be advised
that spoilers for endgame follow during
the Avengers time heist in which
separate teams of heroes were sent to
different periods of time in order to
retrieve the six Infinity stones long
before Thanos could get his massive
purple hands on them Romanoff and
longtime partner in crime Clint Parton
aka Hawkeye aka Ronan are dispatched to
the planet Boromir to secure the soul
stone the pair meet the ghostly red
skull who informs them that they would
have to deal with the same quandary
faced by Thanos an infinity war in order
to possess the stone one must give up
that which they love realizing the
ramifications of the situation the old
friends proceed to fight to the death
that is for the right to be the one to
go over the cliff making the ultimate
sacrifice so that the other might
complete the mission in the end
Romanoff plunges to her doom leaving
Barton in possession of the stone and
faced with the unenviable task of
returning to the present day to inform
the Avengers that Romanoff was no more
as New York Times pop-culture reporter
Kyle Buchanan noted on Twitter for Mears
not exactly a great planet for redheads
soon crew soon it was a sacrifice only
fitting for a character who had a lot of
red in her ledger and was driven by a
need to wipe it out but some fans saw it
as an unfortunate example of fridging a
trope in which a female characters death
is used to drive the motivations of male
characters the trope gets its name from
an issue of Green Lantern in which Kyle
Rayner literally discovers his deceased
girlfriend stuffed into his refrigerator
in their interview the Russos defended
their decision by bringing up multiple
points first and foremost the fact that
in an all-out brawl between Black Widow
and Hawkeye the eventual victor would
necessarily be determined not just by
who wanted it the most but by who was
the most skilled Giarrusso explained
it's a fight to see who's going to kill
themselves
it's a crazy
set for a scene and as you've seen in
the Avengers she's a better fighter than
he is so when it comes down to a fight
between the two of them
she wins but that was far from the only
factor in defending their choice the
directors explained that in essence
Romanoff was motivated by her desire to
see her friend redeem himself after his
stint as the bloodthirsty Ronin and
reunite with his lost family who had all
been dusted in the decimation Anthony
Russo told DW we opened the movie on
hawkeye's family she reminds him of it
in the scene they both may have the
mission in that moment where they're
saying I'm not going to let you kill
yourself but Hawkeye has mixed agendas
there which I feel takes the edge off
his focus in a way that doesn't apply to
Romanoff Joe Russo continued to relate
that widows choice plays into the larger
theme of endgame which is the opposite
of that explored an infinity war the
theme of the movie is can you change
your destiny and what does it cost to do
it and are you willing to pay that cost
it's a resounding yes from the Avengers
an infinity war they said we don't trade
lives and there was a desire to protect
and in this movie there's now a desire
to sacrifice in order to accomplish the
goal the director continued to say that
this specific theme of sacrifice was
appropriate to Romanovs character arc
going from a mercenary style owner to a
full-fledged protector who sees her
survival as being secondary to the goal
of the Avengers the only real family
she's ever known to save the universe
itself from untold destruction I think
that that's a natural progression right
well the first thing we're going to do
is try to protect everybody and then
when you realize it can't work that way
then true heroes step up and are willing
to sacrifice for the greater good
it's an idea explored in multiple Marvel
Cinematic Universe offerings from Steve
Rogers his willingness to face certain
death at the conclusion of Captain
America the First Avenger divisions
insistence on sacrificing himself so
that Thanos will be thwarted in his
attempt to possess the mind stone in
infinity war black widow fans always
knew she'd go down fighting and she did
not against the forces of evil but
against her most beloved ally for the
right to be the one to die so that the
other might be able to live in peace for
perhaps the first time check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Avengers
endgame are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]